[Music]
the book of Henri is directed by Colin
Trevorrow and stars Naomi Watts as a
mother trying to raise two kids one of
whom played by Jaden Libra her is
extremely smart for his age he's
essentially a genius and far beyond his
other classmates in regards to learning
and his younger brother is played by
Jacob Tremblay and the film starts out
as a very nice fun family movie where
everyone's happy and it feels like
everyone's safe they're riding their
bicycles around in a nice neighborhood
there's a tree house they build
complicated contraptions together to
have fun until the older kid realizes
that there might be something sinister
going on next door with one of his
friends at school and that's where the
film gets considerably darker I was
excited for this movie because I liked
when Colin Trevorrow tackles something
original and getting to talk to him and
interview him I learned that that's
something that's very close to his heart
he really wants to make original movies
and he feels that the audiences today
are really begging for that type of
entertainment and I think the book of
Henry is one that they'll appreciate in
that regard specifically because this
movie really isn't like any other film
it's very unique and very different and
they do break a lot of rules the movie
shifts in tone very harshly about
halfway through it gets a lot darker
than I anticipated and I was honestly
sitting in the theater surprised at what
I was looking at I'm shocked that they
actually got away with it and it worked
in my opinion in the movie it really
takes you by the collar and kind of
shakes you and you're like okay that was
a lot more realism than I was expecting
in this moment let's see what happens
now and I could see that turning a lot
of people off because the movie is
marketed as one thing and it turns into
something more sinister which will most
certainly rattle people it did for me
and it worked for myself because I
appreciate that when I go to the movies
I like not knowing everything going in
it's really refreshing to see a film
that is a total change of pace and it's
ballsy there are decisions that are made
towards the second half of this movie
that I was actually biting my
fingernails thinking oh I don't boy I
don't know how people are going to react
to this and I think it could cause some
controversy amongst people but I think
the majority are going to be impressed
by
the originality that's here let's talk
about the performances because across
the board they're all fantastic Dean
Norris plays the evil stepfather who
lives next door and the young kid played
by Jayden Lieber her is also really
strong here a performance that's far
beyond his years
this kid suspects that this father is
involved in some very unsavory things
Naomi Watts is always good but she
really shines in the last half of this
movie because her character has to make
a lot of really hard choices and Jacob
Tremblay once again is giving a really
good performance as a kid and he's
someone to continue to look out for for
all the kids in the movie to stand out
for me was Maddie Ziegler I thought that
she was really good and very understated
she doesn't have a lot of dialogue in
the film and so she has to act quite a
bit just through the expression on her
face one sequence in particular during a
talent show she was brilliant she has to
do a lot of really physical things
during this performance while also
conveying a lot of pain through her face
and she was so so good
Colin Trevorrow clearly is very good at
working with actors where the film
falters for me a little bit is the
second half and the characters have to
make some tough decisions and do some
things that they're being suggested that
they should do and I was just like you
guys are smarter than this you guys are
smarter than this you know this is not
the right path and I was just waiting
for certain things to happen and it got
a little predictable I think is
basically my biggest issue with the
movie after that big shift and the movie
became something else which I
appreciated the film showed its cards to
me pretty quickly I think and some might
feel differently some might be able to
be like I have no idea what's going on
but I kind of could see where the rest
of the film was going even after that
big surprise but overall I think this
might actually be my favorite Colin
Trevorrow movie I enjoy Jurassic world
but I think this is probably a better
film and I like it more than safety not
guaranteed as well I'm going to give the
book of Henry of be guys thank you so
much as always for watching definitely
check out my Colin Trevorrow interview I
had a blast talking to him about this
film and the way he creates original
stories he was a really down-to-earth
guy knows a lot of fun it's going to be
linked at the end also I want to let you
know that my promotion with audible is
still going on if you guys go to
audible.com
- Chris you can get a free 30-day trial
they have hundreds of thousands of
audiobooks I have listened to quite a
bit myself the Star Wars legacy novels
Stephen King's library is there as well
it's such a fantastic service for book
lovers if you don't always have time to
sit down and read a book you can
download these audiobooks to your mp3
player your computer any device that you
could really think of you can probably
get them on there so please check out
audible.com slash Chris and check out
that 30-day trial thank you so much to
audible for continuing to sponsor my
videos you guys are the best and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]